Okay, if we take our t value and square it and put that in the numerator, that
is 4. If we take t and square it again, that is a 4 again. And we add our
degrees of freedom we should get 4 over 4 plus 20. That gives us 4 over 24. And
if we divide 24 into 4 and round to two decimal places, that gives us 0.17 or
17%. Let's try another couple of examples. 4 squared is 16. That goes in the
numerator. Put 16 again into the denominator, and we're going to add 10 to
that. That gives us 16 over 26. And if we divide 16 by 26 and round it two
decimals, that gives us 0.62 or 62%. Third example, well, 1 squared is 1. That
goes in the numerator. Put that again in the denominator. We're to add 9 to
that. That gives us 1 over 10, which is .10, which is 10%. So, in each of these
examples, we see how to get r squared. And I convert it from a proportion to a
percentage and now let's now interpret that. For number one, we'd say that we
can explain 17% of the variation in our deep ended variable by knowing our
other variable. Here we can explain 62%. Here we can explain 10%. Obviously
we're explaining more variation in this example than the other two.